hello everybody my name is
daniel souter i'm a professor in the
department of biological sciences
at purdue university i would like to
thank the organizers for giving me the
opportunity to talk about some of our
work
specifically today about our project
on the role of reactive oxygen species
in actual growth and guidance
alab overall is interested in
understanding the
basic solar and molecular mechanisms of
nervous system
development and regeneration
and in this project specifically we look
at
the role of nox-derived ros
in a nervous system development in two
model systems
in aprilia californica and zebrafish
this title slide here shows two images
on the left side
you see a cross section through
the eye of a wild type zebrafish embryo
at two days of
development two stains in blue nuclear
stain
and in green a stain for retinal gallium
cells
rtc's you see the nice layering
of the retina and also you can see
the knife formation of the optic nerve
as the axons
come together from the neptune boundary
cells exiting the eye
on the right side it looks very
different this
is a section through the eye of a
corresponding
knocks two mutants so this fish
doesn't have any functional energy pitch
oxidase too
this enzyme produces superoxide so this
is
uh this eye is completely
different the layering is not happening
and also the retinal ganglion cells
don't
form axons together and they don't
exist the eye in the same fashion so
this provides evidence that rs from this
complex are really important
in retinal ganglion cell development as
well
as making connections to the brain
so this is the outline of my talk i will
focus
in the background briefly on axonal
growth and guidance
i will then cover our experiments that
we conducted with the octetia model
system
about the role of nox-derived ros
the regulation of growth contacting
dynamics and uric growth
and in the last part i will focus on our
studies
that we conducted in the zebrafish model
system about
nox2 and how it regulates the
development of these retinal tactile
connections i would like to give credit
upfront to the people that did the work
we started all
this work of video monamalai a former
graduate student in my lab that did
these studies in euplegia
which were then picked up by corey
weaver another
gravistune in my lab and he will send
these experiments into the zebrafish
model system which were then followed
by hayley roder a former master student
and offline kersey a graduate student
that just
writed it from my lab recently
so what is actual growth and guidance
so like myself
when i need to find my way to work this
is indicated by this path
here on the aerial view of the westlaw
fed
the neuron growth con has to find its
way
to the park itself so i need to read
cues to find my way from point a which
is where i live to point b is where i
work so that the growth cone
needs needs to look for cues in the
environment
of the embryo these cues can be
different it can be molecular but
also physical cues
now this work is relevant in a number of
aspects
we would like to have a better
understanding of basic
normal nervous system development
indicated here
by this diagram showing human brain
development
but obviously also to better understand
developmental disorders such as l1
syndrome indicated here
or to develop better treatments for
regeneration
following injury and diseases such as
alzheimer's disease
now the neural growth con is this highly
motile structure at the tip
of axons as indicated here in the upper
left
panel this is an image of a hippocampal
neuron
in culture this was recorded in the lab
of my colleague dr
peter hollenbeck and it shows the growth
con at the end of the axon
it's stained for a vaccine in red and
microtubules
in green then
on the right of that we see a schematic
of a typical growth cone with more
details we see the different
domains the peripheral domain or p
domain
the transition zone or t zone and then
the central domain or c
sum these different domains have
different distribution of the
cytoskeleton the avacant cytoskeleton
is particularly in the p domain in the
form of palopodia
indicated in the schematic and
lamborghini
the microtubules are predominantly in
the
central domain but they also penetrate
into the periphery
as you can see in the schematic and they
interact with the
effect inside the skeleton and these
interactions and both cytoskeletons are
really important for neural outgrowth
growth commodity and growthcon guidance
then in the lower panel we see three
images on the left we see
a low power phase contrast image of a
culture
obscene neuron and then we see in the
middle
a differential interference contrast or
dic image
of a girls con and the different domains
again like those with central
domain conditions on amp domain and we
can see the nice structure
of this growth cone and on the right
side correspondingly
we see the cytoskeletal staining of this
gross cone
shown in the middle so in red f-actin
and in green microtubules
so how do applications look like
if you have never seen athleisure these
are invertebrates
live in the ocean they're really cool
animals and they've been used quite a
bit
in nervous system studies uh
why because their nerve cells are very
large
and people have used them to do
electrophysiology
we're using them for imaging purposes
because these growth cones are so
large you have seen on the scale bar
that these crows comes can be as wide
as 100 micrometer
this also allows us to do very nice
quantitative studies both with respect
to dynamics but also mechanics
just an example of that is shown here so
this slide talks
about measuring microtubule dynamics
using the technique
called fluorescent speckle microscopy
developed by
claire waterman store and ted solomon
and this technique is in principle very
simple
it uses the low labeling of filament
structures
by incorporation of only a small amount
of labeled subunits such as tubulin in
this case
and then you get a speckled appearance
of the microtubule
as indicated here in the lower panel
this is from our work
what you see here is a time-lapse
montage
where you see different time
points of a single microtubule growing
and shrinking and also translocating
so the time is going from left to right
and
the distance is showing along the y-axis
and these time intervals are five
seconds here
we color-coded the growing microtubule
in green
at the same magnitude when it shrinks in
magenta you can see the little dots
and an internal dot or speckle is
providing a reference point for
translocation
the addition of new dots provide us
with the ability to quantify the rate of
assembly or shrinkage
so i would like now to move on to
our story about rs signaling in nervous
system development
so this diagram talks about
rs concentrations their sources and
their effects
so they are both extortionist sources on
the right
and endogenous sources and many are
listed here and both ultimately affect
the
concentration of rs so on the right you
will have high concentrations on the
left lower concentrations
and these are also affected by
antioxidant defenses
as indicated here so it's well known
that at two high concentrations of rs
you have impaired physiological function
your observative stress your aging
of diseases and damage to the cell
now more recently work from our lab and
others have shown that if you have too
low
rs as shown here on the left you also
have compared
physiological functions and some
examples of that
are decreased motility decreased
proliferation
effective host defense and defective
gravity perception so it appears
now that somewhere in the middle is the
best for cells
so whereas homeostasis where you have
normal growth and metabolism
and normal functioning signaling
password
now what about rs in the nervous system
obviously the brain
needs a lot of oxygen and therefore the
brain is particularly vulnerable
to obsolete stress secondly
it has been shown that nadph oxidase
derived rs
have been implicated in
neurodegenerative diseases
such as alzheimer's and parkinson's and
als but also
following injuries such as spinal cord
injury
however there's also evidence that
ross derived from energy pitch oxidation
play a role
in normal neuronal function such as
differentiation
synaptic function and plasticity and
gravity perception
so we work here is to ask the question
do
rs play a role in axonal roles and
guidance
so moving on to the second part now to
our studies
on rs in growth commutality and active
dynamics
in the application model system
again these were conducted by vidya and
corey weaver
so what are our hypothesis so with
respect to growth we think
the most simple hypothesis could be that
intermediate rs concentrations are shown
here in the middle in the green
are best for optimal euro growth while
too high concentrations on the right
and too low concentrations on the left
will reduce neurogrowth
with respect to growth con guidance we
can envision
multiple scenarios but some simple
hypotheses
are depicted here if you think about
a repulsive q indicated by the red
gradient on the right side the growth
con
would turn away from that source this
could be mediated by an
increase of rs as indicated here by the
red color
on the left side on the other hand if
you have an attractive positive
q such a q could introduce
a small increase in rs levels that
actually has a positive effect
so depending on the level of cross cones
in the cytosol of the growth cone
you may get either positive or negative
effects and that kind of correlates with
the
curve on the left side the growth curve
this diagram talks about the
molecular pathway that we envisioned for
some of these responses
so it starts all with a guidance queue
for example click 2 binding its receptor
and starting an initial signaling
cascade
this signal in cascade initially then
activates
the nadph oxidase in this case nox2
nox2 is a multi-sodium enzyme complex
that has two components in the plasma
membrane
in green here nox2 and in purple p22
but they are not sufficient in this case
because they're being activated by
cytosolic subunits uh labeled here as
p67 p47 and p40 as well as
rack in its gtp bond form
26 objects come together then
the complex produce the superoxide on
the outside of the cell from
oxygen this quickly converts into
hydrogen peroxide
either on its own or by enzymatic
reactions
and then hydrogen peroxide can
interact and react with the cell surface
but also go back into the cell through
channels
inside the cell additive peroxide can
modify a number of proteins
possibly signaling molecules such as
sarc cytoskeletal proteins such as actin
which ultimately changes the dynamics
and the organization of the act inside
the scalp
so that's our hypothesis now let's look
at some
data in this part of the talk so this
here which i show you evidence that
reducing ros levels reduces
attack the top panel shows on the left
again
uh rosecon schematic you already have
seen that
and then two images of a control rose
under normal condition
dic in the middle and effecting the
microtubule staying in red and green
respectively on the right side
on the lower panel this growth con has
been treated with an antioxidant
called pvn so this is not an inhibitor
so we have to use
millimolar concentrations to
significantly
reduce rs levels in these growth cones
and the effect of that is in here very
clearly in the middle panel
you see the growth gun becomes flatter
phytopodia extend and
ultimately stall and don't grow anymore
and also the central domain
grows forward and the ruffles in the
transition zones disappear
when you look under the hood at the side
of this code then you can see that the
effect inside the skeleton is much
diminished you see that
in panel b double prime so there is less
attracting compared to control
and also microtubules extend towards the
periphery so major changes with the
cytoskeletal amounts rearrangements
and also the growth cone dynamics
when we then specifically inhibit nadph
oxidases
with an inhibitor in this case
the inhibitor is called vas
2870 that's in the lower panel we again
reduce the effecting content so the top
panel shows
the vehicle control the mso the ic on
the left
exactly stain on the right typically
done
with poloidin and then the lower panel
shows another growth concrete with 5
micromolar of this nox inhibitor mass
2870 for 70 minutes
so a significant reduction is effecting
content
and when we look at uric growth
this is on the next slide and here is
quantified total uric length per cell
in three different conditions medium
control
dmso vehicle control and then the nox
inhibitor bus 287
in this case two micro molar
concentration
treated for a day so on day zero before
drug addition
the total neural lengths per cell in
these three groups are
the same very similar but then
one day in drag you can see from the
black bar
that the new red lens is significantly
reduced compared to two control
conditions then we wash out the drug in
this case
the cells are treated for a full day
with this dose
there is no reversible effect here and
the new rest
has stayed short while the control group
still continues to grow
so north inhibition reduces neuron
growth
so depending on the species for example
humans we have
seven members of the family of nox
enzymes and they're listed here you have
different numbers
they can be distinguished based on the
activation mode
and so what you see on this schematic
taken from a review by the darm krauser
you can see in the upper left
the knox 1 complex then in the upper
middle and the knox 2
on the upper right knock 3 and the lower
level
on the left knox 4 middle knox 5 and on
the right
deworx1 and 2. they all have this
enzymatic subunit that does the electron
transfer from nadph onto molecular
oxygen producing
superoxide shown here in red but they
are different in the way
they are regulated and activated
knocks one two and three are regulated
by cytosolic subunits
oxford is constitutively active
and of five and the two doors are
calcium regulated
now we were curious to see whether any
of these are actually localized in
occluding growth cons we are fortunate
to find antibodies that are actually
specific for some of these subunits
we've got these antibodies from mark
quinn
and one two nodes two and one to the
cytosolic subunit
p40 here are the western blots showing
that they're pretty specific
to absolutely your proteins and then
here in the middle and on the right we
see the corresponding immunolabeling
so these are slightly permalink cells we
see a punctual distribution
showing that these proteins are both
membrane associated and as you can see
in the case of nox2
also quite present
in the centerline on organelle membranes
now the next slide we have done a triple
stain
of these two subunits of nox2
along with factory so
in the upper panel you see each
individual stain
for the three different proteins and
then
on the lower panel first the cryptal
color overlay
and then zoomed in in that region of
interest
first the dual overlay of nox2 and p40
and you can see while labels are closed
there's not a whole lot of
yellow here there's not much
colloquialization
and this is likely because these growth
cones have not been stimulated with any
agent
but under the same condition same growth
when you look at
p40 and that actin you can see
that many labels for p40 are actually
coloralized with effect
so that suggests that the cytosolic
suburban
force actually is associated
significantly
with the effect in cytoskeleton under
non-stimulated condition which has also
been shown
for other cytosolic subunits in other
cells now the next slide
shows what happens when you stimulate
the growth cone
with a particle that's coated
with the telovision protein we call this
the
restrained bead interaction assay to use
growthcon advance in the upper left you
see
a dlc image you see that particle
at the right and this holds in place
with a micropipette you can see the dark
shadow of that
you can see how the central domain
actually moves towards that
right particle it's a glass b
go to the baby cam then in the other
images you can see knox ox2p40 and the
color overlay
and what you can clearly see here is
that there's not only more
of those two proteins around the
adhesion side but they're also
co-localized
significantly this adhesion side
suggesting that
the activation of lobster may play a
role in this process here in
adhesion in use advanced and this is
quantified here
the right panel in for experiments
so the rbi area means the beat area the
adhesion area
where you have more colloquialization
than in adjacent
areas
so moving on to the last part of the
talk
about the role of knox 2 now
specifically in
regulation of the development of retinal
textile connections in the zebrafish
this is worked by corey weaver hello
roser
australian thursday
so why zebrafish so
obligation is great for cell culture
studies as i mentioned because these
cells are big they're great for
quantifications of time lapse
fluorescence and biophysical experiments
however there are significant
limitations in activity as well
there is no knockout or transgenic lines
there's no individual imaging capability
they are difficult to breathe and there
are invertebrates on the other hand
zebrafish they are genetically tractable
they are great for individual imaging
they develop fast
have many embryos it's a
well-established developmental model
system and their workplace
so just as an example what you can do in
sierra fish this is an example
of imaging in the living civil fish
brain of an embryo
using a specific line that expresses
fluorescent protein
gfp in retinal garment cells but only in
a few cells and this is called
sparse labeling the line description is
given here on the right
and what you actually see here is you're
looking
at the axonal terminals
in panel a a couple and then in panel b
in more detail at high resolution at
different time points
10 minutes intervals the growth comes in
the file of courier dynamics
of the retinol government cell acts on
the growth comes in the optic tectum
indicated here on the left side in the
schematic that's where
the original gaming cells innervate the
brain
so it's a very uh powerful mobile system
and technique we actually did this year
with livestream microscopy
which allows you to do high resolution
imaging for extended time periods
without
harming the sample
now we started the studies by treating
these zebrafish embryos
with an ox inhibitor in this case
cholesterol
for a four hour time window indicated
here in the upper left
2.5 micro molar then washing out the
drug
and then fix and stain or looking in
a live fish in specific lines that
express fluorescent proteins
and results are shown here first the
control
without the drug in the upper image you
see
looking at the eyes in our throttle view
the two eyes and this is a line that
expresses
tfp in regular ganger shells on the
ground five promoter
this is at 48 hours post fertilization
so this is normal
you can see the arctic chiasm labels
there
and the lower image shows one day later
the innervation of the optic tectum by
these axons detectors are labeled on on
both sides of the brain
now if these fish were treated with the
nox inhibitors celestrol as
indicated in the upper left for four
hours then we see some major changes
the ganglion cell layer is widened
indicated by that bracket
you don't see the optic path that well
it's still there it's
enhanced in the insect and also
the areas of the optic tectum that are
innervated are small
and some of these effects can actually
be rescued by
treatment of hydrogen peroxide such as
the thickness of the optic nerve and the
area of innervation in the tectum but
not the thickness of the ganglion cell
layer and this is quantified
down here on the left side is
the blitz of the cell layers
in control and then celestrol is wider
it cannot be rescued by hydrogen
peroxide
the middle graph shows the thickness of
the optic nerving control
reduced by celestral but rescued by
hydrogen peroxide by adding back
hydrogen peroxide
and the right panel shows the area of
tactile innervation reduced by knox
inhibition but again partially rescued
by
adding back hydrogen peroxide
the drug experiments are great but we
also wanted to do
a more specific molecular manipulation
by creating mutants
using the crispr cast 9 technique so we
created
knox 2 homozygous mutant
and then looked at the retinogamic cells
the eye
and again at the optic textural
innervation so
this is wild type we see here
the individual channels the retinal
garments are labeled
sn8 nucleus stain and the overlay
we targeted these sky garnets to two
sides we call them guide on a one and
two
one targets very close to the end
terminus two a little bit further in
but both will create non-functional
nodes with both guide rnas when we look
at homozygous mutant these significant
changes
in the retina the very similar to what
we observed
with the inhibitor so the gcl is widened
and this is also quantified here at two
time points 48 and 72 hours
so with both mutations with both
approaches we
see a widening of the gcl
and then we look in the brain in the
optic spectrum
again first control so this is wild type
without the mutation we see
the typical innervation in green here of
the optic tectum
but then with both guidelines
with both types of not knocking out
nox2 we see severe perturbation of the
innovation so
it's diffuse innervated and it's not
compact to the normal normally developed
architecture
and this is quantified by line skins
here on the lower right
for both guide armies so the wild type
would be the black line
and the two guide rna so the knox 2
knockouts
are shown by the red and green
so we also did some rs imaging with
genetically encoded file sentences such
as
root usp 2 or 1 indicated here
and first we did some validation
so on the left side the lower panel
you're looking
at the head of the zebrafish embryo the
two eyes are indicated
when you treat them with hydrogen
peroxide you get more signals when we
treat them with reducing agent dtt the
signals go back
indicated here by our warm colors
then we also looked at cultured original
garment cells
and using the same file sensor
so the left side you see the ic images
at 10.0
and treatment with the guidance cue
sleep 2
after 30 minutes which actually causes
a stalling of the growth car and slig-2
treatment not only halts the growth
chronic also increases growth
coron-hydrogen peroxide levels as
indicated here in the graph in
a double prime so rs levels are
increased
however in the mutants knocks two
mutants this doesn't occur
so slit two increases hydrogen peroxide
levels in an ox two dependent manner
and c2 also holds the growth
furthermore if you do a guidance essay
where we applies a two
in a gradient fashion in an angle
indicated here by the arrow
these are enlarged images of growth
comes from culture
zebrafish written down ourselves
so on the left 10.0 on the right 60
minutes later you can see
slipped two in the upper panel you see
the chromosome turns to the left
while in the lower panel we add
celestrol and oxygen emitter together
with the sleep two gradient
and then the repulsive effect of sleep
two is abolished so the growth come kind
of enormously
as you see on the lower right this is
quantified again on the right
you can see that the normal effect of
sleep two which
is causing a negative angle
is abolished by the presence of an ox2
individual
so the last set of a data is shown here
this is in vivo data again
uh showing a retrogame cell axon
staining in the arctic tectum
as well as statistics in wild type
knox 2 heterozygous and also a double
heterozygote for knox 2
and the c2 receptors robo 2 which is
called
asteroid so that's the double
heterozygous
so when you quantify the area of
innervation you actually find
that an ox two heterozygote fish
and that's shown here on the right
doesn't have significantly reduced
area of innovation as well as the
asteroid heterozygospase and that's the
the green triangles but in combination
the double heterocycle not too fast
right
has actually reduced inertia this
suggests that these two
proteins nox2 and robot2
may be the same pathway
so this is the pathway we think about uh
slip two gigantic binds to receptor rule
the cube
starting a signaling cascade that
ultimately activates nox2
producing superoxide hydrogen peroxide
and then ultimately affects downstream
target proteins such as cytoskeletal
proteins
and signaling molecules such as sarc
which ultimately affects
axonal growth and guidance that's our
current
model i would like to summarize and
conclude
so first i showed you that lowering
growth on rs levels binocular division
reduces
effect on content but also effective
dynamics
and uric growth then i showed you that
pharmacological knobs inhibition in the
zebrafish embryo inhibits
the development of retinotectal
connections
and this can be confirmed with nox2
homozygous mutants and then we also
showed you some in vitro data with
culture neurons
that nox inhibition abolishes the
guidance responses
of rtc axons to sleep too but we also
found that for other cues such as egynef
and neptune so in summary these findings
suggest a role for knox to derive
interactive oxygen species actual roles
and guidance
last but not least i would like to thank
the people involved here so this is a
recent
picture of our love i would like to
thank all my students and collaborators
listed down here on the left side in
this project
and of course also all the funding
sources from nih and assets
jana spinal cord the injury research
program
and also purdue thank you very much for
your attention
thank you